cela se passe en allemagne où on se
prépare à fêter les 10 ans de la chute
du mur de berlin
oui avant les célébrations très
fastueuses qui sont prévus dans ce pays
voici comment une toute petite ville de
l'extrême ouest évoque la période
communiste un hôtelier unités bizarre de
faire vivre ses clients à leur
est-allemande celle d'avant le mur
reportage de notre correspondant
olivier werner il n'y a que dix hôtels
dans tchao
ils se ressemblent tous à peu de choses
près il n'y en a qu'un seul qui offre
des chambres avec vue sur l'est et un
première vue c'est un beau pot un
militaire qui agit pour son pays
l'allemagne de l'est
un petit moment s'il vous plaît contrôle
des passeports ils sont venus pour ça
pour revivre ces moments de terreur pour
que leurs petits enfants aussi
ressentent ces tremblements dans les
jambes le coeur qui s'accélère la gorge
qui se nouent quand l'officier fait face
pour vous dévisagent et et vous
interrogez les images des sons aussi
caractéristique des années
honecker
quand j'ai entendu frapper à la porte
oui ça c'était bizarre devant la porte
de l'hôtel
leveaux peau attend le client de pied
ferme
après un premier contrôle on doit passer
à la caisse pour se délester de ses deux
marques et l'échangé en marque
est-allemand on croit rêver devant ce
mur de la honte reconstitué
vous en voulez le patron était au
chômage il y a 6 mois il a retrouvé le
sourire aujourd'hui
sa formule est l'oeuvre d'un
publicitaire
oui une idée folle au départ simplement
rappeler ce qu'était la rda et que ce
soit une découverte pour ceux qui
ignorent tôt et connaisseurs quant à eux
apprécier les nostalgiques apprécieront
la chambre ça devrait plaire aussi aux
américains et aux japonais très attendu
ici mais encore invisibles dans les
couloirs les incontournables tableau du
personnel méritant figure en bonne place
le vau pau doit goûter la soupe de
légumes tous les soirs elle doit être
comme elle était il ya dix ans un
mangeable beaucoup plus vrai que nature
qui avoue attendre des clients quelques
bons pourboires
la serveuse a été formé pour énerver les
consommateurs à qui il est demandé par
exemple d'attendre pour être placé oui
c'était comme ça on a retrouvé des
choses qui n'existent plus chambres
petit déjeuner vaut pour compris ses 300
francs 22 marques est-allemand pour un
clin d'oeil émouvant et éprouvant avec
l'histoire